In the discipline equals freedom
field manual. The section fear reads,
how do you overcome feel
fear of failure step go.
But a previous entry reads,
I don't want you to
overcome fear of failure.
I want you to be afraid of
failure. Mind elaborating. Yeah,
clearly there's a dichotomy here.
I know it's my favorite word apparently
according to Dean lister. Yes, I agree.
There is a dichotomy here because fear
is something good that you should take
advantage of. So it's kind of good to
be afraid because it keeps you on edge.
Agile keeps you from slacking.
It keeps you preparing as much as you
possibly can and all that stuff is good.
But at the same time, yes, if you go too
far to the other end of the spectrum,
fear gets a hold of you
and you can't overcome it.
So you freeze or you cower or you runaway.
And none of those are good reactions.
So what I obviously failed to
communicate well in the book,
discipline equals freedom field manual
is the dichotomy between these spectrum,
the spectrum of fear that you can have.
So if you have no fear whatsoever,
no fear. Well guess what? You get
cocky. You can get arrogant. Um,
if you have too much fear, you can't even
get out of the gate. You just freeze.
You hesitate. So like all dichotomies,
you got to balance those two.
The, and
the way you balance those two is to try
and do things that make you feel fear.
Right? And try and do things
that, that make you feel fear.
So that way you get used to it. You
can overcome it, you can deal with it,
you can utilize it. If you have a fighter,
you ever hear UFC fighters that I'll
come afraid every time I get in the ring.
Yeah, pretty much everybody. Yeah.
Pretty much everybody I'm afraid.
Cause you're, you're afraid you're
gonna get knocked out. You're afraid.
This is,
you're afraid that you're afraid I'm
gonna lose in front of all my family and
friends and all that. So everyone's
afraid. So what does that fear do?
It drives you to train
harder, drives you to prepare.
It drives you to keep your hands up and
your chin down when you're in the cage.
So yeah, there's a healthy
level of fear. It can also get,
get the best of you. So
keep it balanced. Yeah,
we talked about this
and I think Sam Harris
talk about at first as far as the first
I heard it made a point not to go too
deep into it, but the, where
you know, like this. Okay. Fear,
uh, how do you overcome fear step go.
Right. It's essentially like take action,
be brave in the face of fear, right? But
if there's no fear, it's kind of like,
hmm, you're not really being brave.
You're not, you know, kind of thing.
Well that's true too. Yeah. So consider
that, that notion, right? So you say,
yeah, I want you to be afraid of
failure. Oh yeah. Be Afraid of failure,
but you still got to step. You still
got to go. You still gotta be brief,
you know, kind of thing. So they do
actually kind of compliment each other.
Really. Um, unless you think like,
oh yeah. Overcome fear, meaning like,
I'm not scared of it anymore.
It's literally not figured
that it's always fear,
but it's more, it's less about
the fear being, you know,
reduced to zero. It's
more about being brave,
training yourself to be embraced with
here. Yeah. Embrace the fear and the,
and so to continue with that thought,
in order to embrace the fear,
what do you do? You step. Do
you go into it? So there you go.
There's your answer. Cool.